they came together to discuss trade
economic integration security and
migration U.S President Joe Biden and
prime minister Justin Trudeau of Canada
attended the North American leaders
Summit in Mexico City where their host
president Andre Manuel Lopez stressed
the importance of finding Humane
solutions to cope with the thousands of
people trying to reach the United States
[Applause]
social problems cannot be solved with
coercion we should attempt to discourage
violence and immigration with a
humanitarian approach of opportunities
for the well-being of everyone
people are good by nature but
circumstances sometimes lead people to
take the path of anti-social behaviors
we've made enormous President Biden said
the United States is ready to work on
solving the root causes of migration
we're trying to make it easier for
people to get here opening up the
capacity to get here but not have them
go through that god-awful process we can
do more than merely just make legal
immigration more streamlined but we can
also do it by preventing people from
wanting to have to leave in the first
place
Natalie is from Venezuela she entered
the United States illegally and is now
living in a church in El Paso Texas
President Biden gave us an amnesty and
opened the door for us and on our way
here he closed it and now we're stuck in
limbo
hundreds of thousands are facing the
same uncertainty there was lots of
expectations and new announcements were
going to be made that would have an
impact on the lives of the hundreds of
thousands of migrants on both sides of
the Border immigration Advocates say
that North American countries should do
much more to solve the ongoing crisis
the three leaders also work to repair
their differences over trade trudo and
Lopez obrador have expressed concerns
about Joe Biden's efforts to increase
domestic manufacturing with his buy
American program but the three found
common ground on strengthening Supply
chains and reducing their dependence on
imports from Asia
today we discussed how we can build
reliable value chains on this continent
for everything from critical minerals to
electric vehicles to semiconductors
this is good for workers good for
consumers and good for communities
across our countries
together they represent the largest
trading block in the world accounting
for roughly one-third of the global GDP
while disagreements remain they all
agreed that Corporation is essential
Mexico City